soit revue cas dans le cadre de cette
enquête une perquisition est menée au
ministère de la justice
oui absolument et l'avocat d'eric dupond
moretti est sorti tout à l'heure pour
nous expliquer où on était sept
perquisitions
il nous a informés notamment que le
ministre était présent qu'il y avait des
gendarmes
cette perquisition allait mener par la
cour de justice de la république
suite à plusieurs plaintes déposée par
anticor et par des syndicats de
magistrats
eric dupond moretti est soupçonné
d'avoir utilisé ses fonctions pour
régler des contentieux avec des
magistrats avec lesquels il y avait eu à
faire lorsqu'il était avocat la sphère
la plus connue dans laquelle il a eu des
problèmes avec des magistrats a été la
sphère dite des fadettes c'est à dire
que ces conversations téléphoniques
avaient été examinés dans le cadre donc
de la faire paul bismuth la sphère où
nicolas sarkozy était mis en cause où il
a été condamné en première instance à
trois ans de prison dont un ferme
l'avocat d'eric dupond moretti est venu
nous voir et nous a dit que cette
perquisition avait pris du temps parce
que des coffres datant probablement des
années 60 avait été découvert par les
enquêteurs qui voulaient les ouvreurs
sauf que personne n'avait la clé
évidemment pour cet avocat ses coffres
n'ont rien à voir avec la sphère qui est
reproché à eric dupond-moretti je vous
propose de l'écouter tout de suite cette
perquisition avait été annoncée mardi
soir dans le canard enchaîné
nous regrettons évidemment cette
violation du secret de l'instruction
tout comme nous regrettons le
déploiement de force totalement
disproportionnée auquel nous assistons
puisque en plus des magistrats présents
il ya une vingtaine de gendarmes armés
y participent à cette perquisition c'est
un déploiement de force qui est d'autant
plus incompréhensible que dell annonce
de l'ouverture de l'instruction
le garde des sceaux nous avait demandé
de transmettre à la cjr la totalité des
documents détenus par le ministère de la
justice au sujet des faits dont la cjr
est saisie sont des procédures qui ont
été initiées par son prédécesseur
madame belloubet voilà ce qui a donné
lieu aux plaintes déposées par les
différents syndicats de magistrats dont
je le rappelle avait qualifié la
nomination d'eric dupond-moretti au
ministère de la justice de déclaration
de guerre
le garde des sceaux quant à lui il avait
balayé ces accusations lorsque la sphère
avait été connue lorsque l' enquête
avait été ouverte en janvier je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'il disait à
l'époque
si l'objectif de tout cela comme s'est
d'ores et déjà exprimées par certains
c'est de m'interdire de travailler cela
on seront pour leurs frais mon crime est
d'avoir exercé mes fonctions exactement
quand on l'aurait fait tous mes
prédécesseurs dans des circonstances
analogues mais derrière cette sérénité
affichée et bien cette affaire elle
tombe quand même mal pour eric dupond
moretti qui lie à moins de deux semaines
a été sévèrement battue lors des
élections régionales
une défaite qui a créé des tensions
notamment au sein de l'exécutif il a eu
une prise de bec qui a été rapporté dans
la presse avec le ministre de
l'intérieur il y aura aussi donc dans le
cadre de cette enquête
nous avons appris que jean castex et
bien avait été interrogé par les
enquêteurs
c'était le 7 juin quant à eric dupond
moretti le canard enchaîné et bien a
révélé qu'il pourrait être entendu
prochainement et peut-être être mis en
examen dans le cadre de cette affaire
merci aux cas légers en direct donc lui
ministère de la justice